a new CBS News investigation has found
evidence of mass murder by a Russian
mercenary Army that's responsible for
some of the bloodiest fighting in
Ukraine you'll recall that last week we
showed you how the Wagner group
described as a transnational criminal
organization by the American government
plunders gold and other resources in the
Central African Republic to pay for its
War Machine Deborah patta spoke to
eyewitnesses who describe a massacre
there and we warn you what they reveal
is distressing
The Killing Grounds of grounds of CHA in
the opening months of the war in Ukraine
on every street corner evidence of the
horrors that took place beamed around
the world and quickly investigated as
potential war crimes committed by the
kremlin's troops including Russian
mercenaries from the notoriously brutal
Wagner group
the year before another Massacre but
thousands of miles away in the Central
African Republic town of Bunbury
no International Spotlight no
prosecutors documenting the mass murder
of civilians
and no one to implicate those
mercenaries only a president who turns a
blind eye protected by those same Wagner
gunmen in exchange for lucrative
contracts to mine gold and a country so
gripped by fear not a single atrocity
was reported to a government Commission
of inquiry CBS News has pieced together
an account of that Massacre through
eyewitnesses whose names have all been
changed to protect their identities
car Refugee Medina fled to neighboring
Cameroon after the Russian mercenaries
attacked bambari and seized control of
the family's gold trading business she
was so terrified she hid under her bed
for three days
they were shooting at us from the ground
she said and planes fired from the sky
no idea how many people died
so many people died she sighed it was
hard to count
Medina washed the bodies of the woman
who'd been gunned down the bloodbath her
son Usman told us began shortly before
the Day prayers
it was Total Carnage like Armageddon he
said they spoke Russian
authorities claimed there was an
operation at the time to root off Rebels
but some of the Dead were found at this
local mosque photos taken after the
massacre show Walls pockmarked by
gunfire and the bodies of over 100
mostly civilians were counted their
names recorded by a community health
worker called Mubarak who was later
abducted presumed dead on mubarak's list
was osman's brother hit and killed by a
sniper while running from the gold mine
to help their mother and sister alzina
when they entered our house they ordered
all the men to step out some were
arrested others killed on the spot
Alcina said
many did not come back
she was taken to a Wagner base and raped
we were told the memory is so traumatic
she cannot speak about it her brother
picked up the story after we were forced
to move to a different location for
security reasons she begged me for
forgiveness he later told us and so she
might as well be dead now
another sister suffered a similar fate
they raped her in our home
it became Wagner's house he said they
drank and carried out those heinous acts
Usman carries the way to both his
sister's pain frequently breaking down
weeping in our interviews with him
and asking what his family had ever done
to Vladimir Putin to deserve this
it is an achingly familiar cry half a
world away in Ukraine where civilians
wonder how many more victims of Putin's
bloody war will be added to a staggering
list of tens of thousands of potential
Russian and Wagner war crimes for CBS
morning's Deborah patter Keith
proud of the journalism that Deborah is
doing because she points out rightly so
in her piece that there has not been an
international Spotlight there are no
prosecutors looking to bring those
perpetrators to Justice only this light
that is being shown yeah on those
victims there was a fantastic reporter
yeah it's very upsetting and chilling
what she's telling us it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreak see for yourself
exactly right